c'est lui qui donne son nom à cette
nouvelle place publique henri tranquille
propriétaire de l'ancienne librairie
tranquille et qui n'est pas étranger à
la révolution du même nom l'ancien
stationnement pour les véhicules de
police a l'ambition de devenir un
incontournable du centre ville et pas
seulement pour la nouvelle patinoire où
seront projetées des vidéos axa se veut
un lieu vivant on vient pas juste au
chalet met ses patins on vient au chalet
pour manger lunch et se promener dans
les galeries peut-être qu'on va
organiser une réunion avec des collègues
d'après ce même chose nos patins
convient pacs n'est ce qui devrait être
possible dès mi-décembre pour en arriver
là le projet de près de 80 millions de
dollars a traversé trois administration
tremblay coderre est maintenant plantes
[Applaudissements]
wii voir des braseros y voir des
commerces ont soit quai du vin chaud on
travaille avec des futurs opérateurs
pour développer cette offre cela a amené
l'hiver au centre-ville mieux vivre
l'hiver avec la patinoire mais d'en
faire un lieu aussi vivant l'été je
pense que c'est vraiment important
d'avoir des espaces comme ça pour
permettre aux gens de se rencontrer
parce que concrètement en fait on en
manque d espace de socialisation a joué
centre-ville au sous sol tout est prêt
pour qu'on puisse patiner dès que la
température tombera sous les 10 degrés
avec un système qui permettra des
économies d'énergie qui lui va
transporter la chaleur d'un legic mains
d'un réseau de chaleur échauffés en
grande partie le chalet reste à trouver
quel restaurateurs ouvrira ses portes
ici pour contribuer à l'animation de cet
espace tranquille ici mathieu prost
radio canada montréal